Good morning Hank, it's Wednesday. I'm in
Venice and I'm really sick, but I don't want
to talk about either of those things. I want
to talk about the Evil Baby Orphanage and
our first president, George Washington.
Right, so, Hank, as I'm sure you recall, a
few years ago Nerdfighters came up with the
idea that instead of, like, going back in
a time machine and KILLING evil people when
they're babies, we could go back and kidnap
them and take them to the Evil Baby Orphanage
where, you know, we could rehabilitate them.
Hank, it's obviously a fantastic idea, aside
from the small problem of, you know, time
travel being... quite challenging. But here's
my question, Hank: how do you decide who is
a good candidate for the Evil Baby Orphanage?
Take, for example, George Washington. Terrible
Evil Baby Orphanage candidate, right? Like,
he fought the British in the War for Independence,
he was a huge part of the American constitution,
represented democracy, wooden teeth, six-foot-eight,
weight a frickin' ton, all that stuff. He
was also inarguably REALLY good at being the
American president.
But, Hank, what if our nearly universal assumption
that the American Revolution was a good thing
is wrong? Like, let's say we kidnap George
Washington as a baby and take him to the Evil
Baby Orphanage, "how, if at all, does that
change history?" turns out to be a pretty
interesting question. Let's assume - although
I think this is a bit dubious - that somehow
removing George Washington from history causes
us to lose and/or not fight the Revolutionary
War. It probably takes the United States at
least 70 more years to achieve its independence,
like, let's assume that we're following the
"Canada Model", but we still eventually end
up with a representative democracy, and if
we're following the "Canada Model", some excellent
beer.
Furthermore, as pointed out in M.T. Anderson's
brilliant novel The Astonishing Life of Octavian
Nothing, the revolutionary war was decidedly
a bad thing for the people who most needed
the protection of a government: the slaves.
And Hank, it's almost certain that slavery
would have ended earlier in America if we
had just remained a British colony. Furthermore,
Hank, it's not totally unreasonable to assume
that, with slavery ending in the early 19th
century at some point, we might have avoided
the Civil War, which was the bloodiest conflict
in United States history, resulting in 600,000
dead people.
But it doesn't stop there, Hank, because we
know that one of the key factors in the French
Revolution was that France bankrupted itself
helping us fight our revolution. Now, Hank,
I'm not saying that George Washington - who,
by the way, was a slave-owner - is responsible
for a century of slavery or 600,000 dead people.
I'm just saying that, as usual, the truth
resists simplicity.
So, Hank, here's my non-rhetorical question
for the day: how do we know who's a good candidate
for the Evil Baby Orphanage, given the complexity
of history? And more importantly, how do we
know that we ourselves are not living lives
that could result in us going to the Evil
Baby Orphanage?
Let's continue the conversation in comments
and in Your Pants. Hank, I'll see you on Friday.